[Music]
welcome to the first edition of 105 this
show will recap the Friday action quads
I am your host international arbiter
Michael comer
today we have a winner of round one
Jeffrey Kendall
so Jeffrey attends Linda wood University
he's a proud
Linda wood lion he won his first round
game against a chess local Greg Van
Valkenburg so how was your game against
Greg well you know it was even and then
he Castle queenside the Queen was on the
same diagonal as the King all right
we're here at the conclusion of round
two of the Friday action quads we have
the top guy in a quad 3 richard pope AKA
sassy dad with his a big victory against
a player rated 200 points lower rated
than him so Richard he just got a great
position and just storm rolled the guy
so uh let's see uh play out the game
here all right well we started the game
with pawn to Queen 4th and he played the
Dutch defense not recommended by the way
so I played 8h 3 wishes the court
snowing line he looked at it for a
little bit and thought it looked pretty
harmless so he went ahead and continued
playing the normal Dutch line and then I
played g4 which is the where I sacrifice
a pawn ok but but you know this I know
this backwards and forward I've I've
played it many times so yes or if you do
play the Dutch for whatever reason
dubiously you should be prepared for
this line as Richard was right so we
went ahead and took the pawn I took back
and then he stopped and thought a bit I
thought well there's there's nothing he
could do to me I mean all my pieces are
on the back row so he went ahead and
took it and he was expecting me to play
something like e for to attack the
knight but there's actually a better
move here
Queen to d3 because now the rook and the
Queen
heading down the h-file so is the
recommended move in this position Knight
to f6 not at all it's g6 actually
interesting its g6 and the recommended
its takes takes excuse me
Queen takes this over here and then this
is really the position and if you're a
fan of the Dutch you don't play
positions that look like this so he was
already very good
I don't have gotten in that situation
I'd say so but back to the game where I
had this and he had his knight here and
I had my rope there yep right he did go
ahead and do what you see what you
mentioned Knight oh no we have to edit
that part of the interview cuz now it's
a humiliation here it comes
rook takes and he can't capture either
way if he captures with the rook it's
checkmate and if he capture us with the
knight it's checkmate so that's just how
it went any resigned he's a very nice
guy and and after the game we went over
to a far corner and I showed him how he
should have played it and he promised
he'd never fall into that mess again you
know good way to not fall into the mess
again
don't play the Dutch alright thanks a
lot Richard thank you we are concluded
with the Friday action quads
I'm here with Aiden home part of the
Froyo gang and he took down sassy dad in
the last round how was your game against
Richard I think I did pretty good
he played nah it's gonna Navy anyons
yeah that's another on Orthodox kind of
opening ok Scandinavian all right so
what are your aspirations in chess
because you've been really uh knocking
on the door here and getting better fast
I basically don't think about the money
because it's time I think about the
money little do lose yeah yeah I've had
the same problem I'm just picturing all
that cash and what I'm gonna spend it on
like the Froyo yeah and then you lose
yeah you lose concentration so let me
tell so what is the deal with the Froyo
gang you've got yourself Rex
Selena Alex Aang and of course newman
chen who just won the under 1,200
section so are you guys trained together
you just play together or what's the
deal we play together sometimes after we
train together
well most of the times we just trade I
mean because we don't really see each
other that much unless it's like a
tournament I got you I got you
well there's only the future so bright
for all you guys and I wish you guys the
best of luck and congrats on winning the
$36 tonight
[Music]